there was an interview that took place
in September with the Daily Caller where
the president Donald Trump claimed that
there are more than a hundred pictures
of special prosecutor Robert Muller and
fired FBI director James Comey hugging
and kissing each other and when that was
reported it seemed like an onion article
because this is a really weird thing
it's hard to believe that there are a
hundred pictures of James Comey and
Robert Muller hugging and kissing and if
the pictures did exist it would be
unusual I guess for Donald Trump to have
those pictures we now have follow-up to
that story the FBI has followed up a
BuzzFeed reporter submitted a FOIA
request to the FBI specifically for
pictures of James Comey and Robert
Muller hugging and kissing and the FBI
responded to the FOIA request by saying
they are unable to locate any such
photos not a single one
now that doesn't confirm that no such
pictures exist a FOIA request doesn't
mandate that any related document or
image or video be released but barring
some issue of confidentiality or
national security the FBI would release
such pictures if they had them but they
don't exist because it was ridiculous
from the beginning but what we do have
interestingly enough you know what I'm
getting to
we have video of Donald Trump appearing
to give James Comey a kiss at least it's
an air kiss followed by a hug and what
might be a kiss on the cheek take a look
[Applause]
there are no pictures of robert muller
and james comey hugging there are no
pictures of robert muller and james
comey kissing even though Donald Trump
claimed that he has a hundred but it
appears that we do have video of Donald
Trump kissing for James Comey which is
unusual it's not usually the way you
would expect the president to greet an
adversarial FBI director yeah I mean
maybe the kiss on the cheek in some
cultures that's okay of course yeah but
the air kiss is actually the most
surprising to me this is not important
because anybody thought that Trump
really might have a hundred pictures of
Muller and Comey kissing and hugging
it's important because it's part of this
compulsive lying and megalomania it's a
waste of government resources and tax
dollars that now go to fact-checking
the obvious habitual chronic lying of
Donald Trump it's also arguably sort of
thinly veiled homophobia there's kind of
a subtle implication of hundreds of
pictures of Muller and Comey kissing
each other and I think that that's
probably also an element that there is
something there that Trump thinks is
funny to sort of ridicule beyond just
the political implications of Comey and
Moeller being buddy-buddy as he claims
like would he say the same thing about
you know one one female and one male
like let's say it was like right a Lynch
and Eric Holder I don't think he would
they were a I've got a hundred pictures
of Obama kissing Loretta Lynch no he
wouldn't be saying that and it's
important also because it's an example
of how lies are used briefly and then
there's no follow-up and then six weeks
later you get the truth and it turns out
that just a blatant total lie was told
and no one really cares at that point
and it relates to really important
political issues if you have a president
that is a known habitual uncontrolled
liar that influences and it undermines
foreign policy this is a minor lie but
to a liar they're all just lies and our
allies and our adversaries know that
Trump is a liar and therefore they have
no reason to trust him and this hurts
every American whether or not you voted
for Trump geopolitics is to borrow a
phrase from the internet serious
business and in general world leaders
mostly adhere to sort of trust but
definitely verify and so even if Donald
Trump wasn't a known liar they would be
looking into everything that he says
because that's how geopolitics works or
at least it's supposed to work if you
have the right level of skepticism when
Trump is a known liar and he lies to our
allies and our adversaries they are of
course going to even more be dead set on
exploring the veracity of every single
thing that Donald Trump says and there's
little advantage to lying on that
geopolitical stage and Trump lies on
every stage and whether it's a hundred
pictures of Comey and Moeller kissing or
whether it's a lie told to the French
president or the German Chancellor or to
Kim jong-un it doesn't serve any
positive purpose it doesn't do anything
for you or I or anybody regardless of
whether we voted for Trump and that's
why the lying is so toxic and insidious